another daily cancellation another viral
video that everyone has an opinion about
and most of the opinions are wrong as
usual and this time it's a young lady
named Britney Peach who recently
recorded secretly recorded and posted a
video of herself getting fired from her
sales job with a tech company called
Cloud flare um apparently Britney uh
like literally every other employee
who's ever been fired from any position
ever disagrees with her termination and
feels that she deserves to keep her job
her employer feels otherwise and uh as
it usually goes in this sort of
situation her employer's opinion on the
matter prevails uh after all when your
boss fires you the decision has already
been made that they they aren't asking
you if you're okay with it or how you
feel about it or they're not taking a
poll on the subject they're not bringing
you in and sitting you down and saying
you know if you're okay we're going to
let you if you're okay with it we're
going to fire you it doesn't doesn't go
that way they are informing you that you
are fired and that's it um there's
there's 's almost certainly nothing you
can
say when you're getting that unfortunate
talk there's almost certainly nothing
you can say to change their
mind uh the decision has already been
made and so the only thing you can do is
decide how you'll handle it whether
you'll handle it first of all with some
dignity and
class um and not start
graveling um and also if you will
respond in a way that will increase or
decrease your chances of getting another
job this is this is you know it's
actually get when you're getting fired
this is a big moment in your career you
know it's it might be the end of this
current job but it's it's a it's a
pivotal moment in your career because um
whether or not you get a better job in
the future will will hinge uh in large
part on how you respond in this moment
both in the moment and in the in the
moments that that come after well uh
unfortunately Britney has chosen to
respond in a way that's going to hinder
her chances of getting another job
because she has decided to respond by
secretly recording the meeting and
posting it to Tik Tok for sympathy and
clout which will absolutely ensure that
every potential employer in the future
will be very wary about hiring her and
most will immediately toss her resume in
the garbage 5 seconds after they Google
her name which they will all do but even
though Britney has decided to implode
her career on camera for all to see
she's still being cheered by the vast
majority of the peanut gallery they're
very impressed with the video and her
performance in it so before we go any
further uh we should probably watch some
of this video first here she is getting
the bad news listen we finished our
evaluations of 2023 performance this is
where you have not met claer
expectations for performance we've
decided to part ways with you yeah I'm
going to stop you right there sure um so
I started August 25th I've been on a
3mon
ramp and then it was 3 weeks of December
and then a week of Christmas and then
here we are um I have had the highest
activity amongst my team um since I've
started I have had three contracts out
done a really great job managing my
deals up until the very end that decided
not to close last minute um so I don't
think that that makes a lot of sense for
me in my cloud flare Journey here so far
also um every single 10one I've had with
my manager every conversation I've had
with him has he has been given me
nothing but I am doing a great job I
have had great activity I have really
great meetings I'm picking up the
products very quickly and um things have
been going really really well I make
really great relationships with my
clients
um so I disagree that my performance
hasn't
been um I haven't met performance
expectations um
when I certainly have just because I
haven't closed anything
officially now we're going to revisit
some of that in just a moment
um but before we do let let's we're
going to fast forward a few seconds
until we get to her employer's
explanation such as it is for her
termination uh so here's here's how they
explain it listen let me carve out the
the two threads um a ladder of why I'm
on this conversation I'll I'll put that
one to the second half and Rosie might
be better to explain the process of who
is giving this information and the prior
piece which is your uh feedback and and
notes about your performance so me add a
little color context to that so um just
for clarification ation you are not
being singled out in this your peers are
also being
collectively um assessed on performance
this is a collective collaboration for
cloud flare so I just want to clarify
that piece I won't be able to add any
kind of specifics on numbers or wait
yeah no can you explain for me why
Britney Peach is getting let
go the I won't be able to go into
specifics for numbers wait why though I
just started I've been working extremely
hard just because I haven't closed
anything that has nothing to do with my
performance on a 3-month ramp with just
one month with two major holidays in the
middle I don't think that has anything
to do with why I should be let go if
that makes sense so I really need an
answer and an explanation as to why
Britney Peach is getting let go not why
Cloud Flair decided to hire too many
people and are now actually realizing
that they can't afford this many people
and they're letting that go if that's
the real answer I would rather just you
tell me that instead of making up up
some bull and telling me that right
before I lose my job from someone that
I've never met
before okay now as mentioned this video
has been viewed millions of times and
most of the comments have been
incredibly supportive of Britney it's
also been picked up by several media
Outlets who also paint Britney as the
hero of the story and for the most part
the peanut gallery has agreed that
Britney uh uh comported herself very
well during this interaction they say
that she was reasonable and well spoken
they're out r that Britney got fired
even though her performance has been
great according to her uh they say that
she was treated coldly and impersonally
like like like she was nothing but a
faceless Cog and the corporate machine
and that's the popular consensus but
again as is often the case the popular
consensus misses the mark uh mostly
misses it anyway so let's go over a few
points
one yes it is dehumanizing and
demoralizing and depressing a lot of
other dwords to get fired over Zoom by
some some corporate boss you've never
even met and one who uses phrases like
Collective
calibration I mean I got to admit to
hear that to hear that at all but to
hear that in the in in the process of
getting fired well we're doing a
collective calibration uh that is that's
like that's like Soul draining like you
could feel your soul being drained out
of your body uh when you when you hear
stuff like that um and so if you watch
this video and you say to yourself
man I never want to work for a company
like Cloud Flair well that makes two of
us right I I'm totally with you but
here's the thing Britney did work for a
company like Cloud flare yes she's
treated like a cog in the corporate
machine but she chose to get a job as a
cog in the corporate machine she was
working remotely apparently for a tech
company with thousands of
employees like that's as impersonal as
you can get that's the very definition
of being a cog in the corporate machine
getting fired over Zoom by a company
like that it is dehumanizing but working
over Zoom for a company like that is
also one could argue
dehumanizing it's understandable if you
would rather be dehumanized by a
paycheck than by a pink slip but it does
make your complaints about the ladder a
little bit less credible start the new
year off knowing that you found the
right life insurance to protect your
family with policy genius policy genius
makes it easy to compare life insurance
quotes from top companies and find your
lowest price uh their license agents
work for you not the insurance companies
that means you can trust their guidance
because they don't have an incentive to
recommend one insurer over another there
are no added fees and your personal
information is kept private a good life
insurance plan can give you peace of
mind that if something happens to you
your family will be able to cover
mortgage payments College costs or other
expenses life insurance through your
workplace may not offer uh enough
protection for your family's needs and
it won't follow you if you leave your
job since life insurance typically gets
more expensive as we age Now's the Time
to buy house policy genius makes the
process so much easier with policy
genius you can find life insurance
policies that started just $292 per year
for a million dollars of coverage some
options offer a same day approval and
avoid unnecessary medical exams save
time and money and give your family a
financial safety net with policy genius
head to policy genius.com Walsh or click
the link in the description to get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save that's
policygenius.com
Walsh people are giving her credit for
how she handled herself on the call well
personally I found her to be smarmy and
condescending but that's beside the
point the point is that she shouldn't
get credit because she was performing
for a camera that the other party didn't
know was there okay this is I don't know
why people struggle with this but like
when someone records themselves doing
something it it doesn't make sense to
give them credit oh they really handled
that well well they're recording
themselves they're doing it for you to
impress you okay like maybe that's how
they would respond in a normal situation
the camera wasn't rolling but we don't
know
that you know it's it's not a whole lot
different from these Tik Tok videos you
see of somebody like um uh giving money
to a homeless man or something doing
something nice for a homeless guy you
say well this is what humanity is all
about no it's not he's doing it for the
camera okay it's not in he's only doing
it for the camera he's not it's not even
about the charity at all do you really
not understand
that so in this case she filmed it
knowing that she would posted to Tik Tok
afterwards that means that nothing she
says on the call can be taken as honest
or Genuine sure the corporate drone
managers firing her they weren't being
authentic or human but neither was she
like they were following the corporate
script and she was performing for a Tik
Tock audience the whole thing was an
orgy of
inauthenticity and that decision on her
part is one that again will haunt her
for the rest of her professional life no
employer wants to hire someone who who
might secretly record them and then use
the video to smear them on social
media um even if she was the greatest
saleswoman in the
world it it it it still would not be
worth the
trouble okay but as a saleswoman who
didn't make a sale in 4 months it's
definitely not even close to worth of
trouble which brings us to point three
three the peanut gallery complains just
as Britney herself complained that she
wasn't given a reason for her dismissal
that's not entirely true they said it
was performance related she admits that
she hasn't closed the sale since she got
the job four months ago uh she says that
that's okay because she she manages her
meetings well even though she doesn't
convert those meetings into sales but
it's not much of a strain to speculate
that her employer doesn't find that
reason very compelling like they don't
give a damn if you're if you're good in
meetings or if you get along with your
co-workers or even if you work hard they
care about results and if you aren't
getting results you aren't doing your
job and that's most likely why she was
fired is it harsh is it tough is it
unkind sure probably I guess but but
that's life and life has not changed
much in this regard okay in
pre-industrial times um the only result
that mattered was whether you had a good
harvest or whether you had a successful
hunt and if you didn't you died and that
was that and now the result that matters
at your sales job is whether you make
sales if you don't you die
metaphorically in a professional sense
which is at least preferable to the
literal sense but the principle is the
same now could the other people on the
call have given her more specific
information about why she was fired yeah
maybe they could have but there's a
reason why employers are vague in these
situations it's because in many cases if
they tell the truth if they're totally
Frank they'll get
sued employers try to be as vague in
general as possible to avoid
liability so hypothetically and I I
don't know anything about this woman I
don't know if this is true just
hypothetically
if um yeah she's lagging in sales but
maybe there's people that are lagging in
sales too and they don't get to fire but
they chose to fire her because on top of
lagging in sales she's also just
obnoxious and unpleasant and nobody
wants to work with her like how if that
was the case well that that that's
that's a valid reason for her to be the
one to get fired but they can't say that
you know especially in these corporate
they're not going to say well you're
just an obnoxious unpleasant person
nobody wants to be around you so we're
getting rid of you you're not worth the
trouble like you're not worth the
trouble they can't say that
um because then they'll get sued and so
and so what happen like yes that would
be the more human thing also more
helpful it's a lot more helpful to tell
somebody that so they maybe can have
some chance of self-improvement but uh
you know the the litigious Society we
live in means that uh just honesty goes
out the window Humanity goes out the
window and now guess what now that they
have to worry about having the
conversation recorded and posted to Tik
Tok they're going to be even more vague
and general so if you thought that that
meeting was cold and impersonal wait
until you see how cold and impersonal
they will get when the possibility of
tick tock infamy is hanging over every
meeting of this type so this this Hero
has just guaranteed that the problem
she's exposing will only get a million
times worse because of her for um
finally you
know it's hard getting fired um like to
it's a hard thing to be fired I
understand that I I've been through it
more than once humiliation anger anxiety
sadness resentment like a lot of very
difficult emotions are bowled up into
one messy jumble when you get fired uh
it sucks it s in a word it sucks to get
fired but here's the part that might
come as news to many of our genz friends
just because you're going through
something difficult just because you're
feeling bad about something just because
you're suffering a setback that doesn't
mean that you need to make a national
Scandal out of it that doesn't mean you
need to broadcast it to the world and
make yourself into history's most
oppressed victim you're dealing with
something that millions of people have
been through your version of it may be
worse than some uh but it's not nearly
as bad as most for instance if you're
single and you have no kids and you get
fired your experience is automatically
not that bad compared to to the many
millions of people who've been fired
when they have kids that depend on them
right now that doesn't make your firing
any less painful but it does make it a
whole lot less uh noteworthy okay and it
does mean that sometimes in life you
just have to take your lumps and move
on you just
do and and we we can't like nobody wants
to say that anymore like no one wants to
say anymore yeah that's that's that
sucks that
happened okay
hey like we're all moving on now with
our lives and you need to
also it's just that's it yes we we have
acknow but it's hard yeah okay we all
acknowledge that we get it but it's
really hard yeah okay we all we
acknowledge it's a really hard thing but
it happened and that's it like deal with
it um do you want my pity okay well you
have my pity and and take that and $150
and it'll get you a KitKat at a vending
machine probably not even that with
inflation so anyway stop looking for
pity stop looking for victim points get
a grip collect yourself move on with
your life it's your only choice so you
might as well take
it or else I must say that you just like
our friend Britney are today
canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to daily ir.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there